look let's be honest and I've told you
this before when we were in England I
was like what the hell are you guys
doing sorry yeah of course we on the
rooftop that day we've normally rooftop
me and Jamie Bell yeah
kicking off the moss yes as the famous
lyrics go yeah mate amazing I'm
absolutely overjoyed I really am what
does this mean to you to take this thing
home look you know when you go to drama
school in London yeah you train and you
dream of being an actor who works in the
great theatres in London they all made
the Donmar the National Theatre the
Royal Court sure and you hope that
occasionally you'll get a commercial
that you know pays the rent or the
mortgage or whatever so to be working in
films to be portraying an icon and then
to be a you know win an award for it
it's that it is quite actually literally
the stuff that dreams are made of I
don't know if you saw Elton's face did
you see his face
he was he he was over the moon he's
already on a flight back to Australia I
think but yeah he's it so it's amazing
and also for him and Bernie who it
defies belief they've never won an award
together before really apparently not no
so it's it's absolutely golden that it's
worked out this way there is a special
relationship you two have had we have
seen it the way you have bonded and you
mean so much to him so you both walk
away with Golden Globes tonight how
special is that it's um it's amazing and
it's a lovely thing of I think it's
quite unusual you know that for the for
someone who's so universally known to be
affected in a film and then also for the
actor for his boast to win something on
the same night connected with the same
film that feels really special and it
feels very in the spirit of the journey
and I'm and we're both overjoyed okay in
the spirit of the journey what are you
doing tonight I mean come on come on
Italian food with my my mother my father
my auntie my sister's my and my team my
representatives we are going to go and
have lots of very heavy very fattening
Italian food and then we are
got a dance if we're not asleep oh no
there'll be parties all night long
there's parties for you all night long
right hope so yeah come on and also will
you or is there another chance that you
will have to sing with Elton again I
hope so I mean III would I don't I I
mean that's that's up to that's up to
the big man but I mean I I would imagine
there will be another opportunity
somewhere whether it's imminently or in
you know the next couple of years I'm
sure it will happen again where does
this thing go
it's toss up it will either be on my
mother's mantelpiece yeah or it will be
on I have a very lovely set of shelves
in my living room and it might take
center stage there can you imagine what
it's like if your mom's friends come
over and it's just like oh they don't
touch Terrans are goldglove
and we have a slightly raucous dog in my
mother's house i presiding over sit
again knocked over and dented and the
transformation into Elton it seeps into
your soul will it always be a part of
you it's the best role I've ever played
and I'm very confident that when I'm an
aging you know graying thinning actor in
my twilight years I think it will still
be one of the best roles I've ever
played and I'm really comfortable with
that because you know I love him I'm a
huge admirer of him and his legacy and
you know it's been my great honour to
portray oh I'm gonna tell you something
this has been a special journey and I am
so happy to see you
it has been incredible to watch the work
go in you know and I saw the work that
you put in busted your butt on this
thank you for a jewel a shamanic you hey
by the way which outfit did you keep I
have the denim jacket from tiny dancer
that's it actually that's it well yeah a
lots of it is the Paramount a lot I
think we'll break in and gives you some
[Music]